voilà comme ça
les chapeaux de se salir on a je vous
attendais bonjour le facteur va
m'apporter deux grands cartons pleins de
chapeau j'ai décidé de faire une
exposition de chapeau pour les enfants
lire toutes sortes de chapeaux
c'est une bonne idée mais ce pas voilà
les facteurs qui arrive
bonjour facteur bonjour mademoiselle
julie alors vous les avez aimés charteau
avalé voilà mais je vais tout de suite
vous cherchez le dernier colline à ce
n'est pas que ce soit vraiment lourd
mais pour sûr c'est encombrant ou je
voulais pons soleil à la bombe on attend
des facteurs je crois que dans l'autre
fois ça sera plus pratique
ah bon alors là voilà écoutez facteur à
la réflexion je pense que sur le
tabouret ça sera encore mieux comme ça
je pourrais tous les états les sept mois
vous vous n'avez pas changé d'avis vous
vous êtes sur moi ne vous moquez pas de
moi facteurs je sais que je suis d'un
naturel vif et désordonnée mais là c'est
l'impatience de voir mes chapeaux je
vous comprends
bon bah écoutez à tout à l'heure je vais
tout de suite vous cherchez le dernier
col
tout à l'heure faites vite oui oui
[Musique]
son joli à m'échapper c'était vraiment
lui en est c'est bien celui là
regarde non pas par là casimir fait
demi-tour un demi-tour wyatt en demi
tours 1 2 3 je ne vois toujours rien et
quasi mais c'est un tour complet regarde
vers le kiosque
ah oui mais il fallait le dire tout de
suite on l'a mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ce chapeau pourquoi ce qu'il se
remet sur la tête
louvier 15 ml julie et cotées aaa mais
moi aussi je suis qu'au caire c'est un
défaut que ce pas bon alors je ne suis
pas coquet ou d'ailleurs c'est un défi
très féminine avons les hommes ne sont
jamais coquet même même maillot du stade
et finalement il ya des exceptions mais
imaginez a tué un homme se mettant un
chapeau si ridicule sur la tête
sûrement pas allons voir julie mais pas
celle où sur ce que nous avons dit elle
serait furieuse part d'un bon pas bon
bonjour julie à salut alors comment vont
me trouver
eh bien tu un château amusant c'est tout
ce que tu trouves à dire à toi quasi mis
en
qu'est ce que tu as tu ne peux plus
parler ou jemappes
oh oui oh kazim et des quelque chose
mais tu m'as demandé de ne pas prononcer
un mot pourquoi pas un jour à il nous
prend soin ne voulait pas que je te
répète ce qu'il m'a dit casimir
qu'est ce que tu veux
eh bien il a dit que tu étais craint
coquette comme toutes les femmes
ah bon tu prétends que les hommes ne
sont pas coupés eh bien oui je lis les
femmes sont cent fois plus coquettes que
les hommes tiens prenons l'exemple du
chapeau jamais on imaginerait des hommes
se mettant de tels chapeau sur la tête
trois noms alors un bon parce que tu
penses que les armes ne porte jamais de
chapeau tarn
parfois nous nous portons des chatons et
c'est uniquement pour se protéger de la
pluie ou du soleil caselli je n'ai pas
été long way bonjour françois bon jour
15 18 heures à je comprends vous êtes
venus admirer les chapeaux pour sûr ils
sont jolis la sent plutôt venu me dire
que seules les femmes étaient assez
coquette pour porter des chapeaux
originaux ans moi gentil ça pas du tout
même qu'un deuil en moi moi je les lui
bien ma casquette un bien sûr facteurs
et les points elle est très jolie votre
carrière mais c'est quand même une
coiffure sobre qui est surtout utile
pour sûr et sans ma casquette
j'attrapais des coups de soleil bon
alors il faut que je m'enlève j'ai jemma
tournée a continué à bientôt mes amis
bon convoi militaire
voilà la peine de discuter j'ai là tout
ce qu'il tout ce dont j'ai besoin pour
ma démonstration les enfants vous venez
ils ont formé les jeux regarder tout ce
que je lire
venez voir françois prétend que
seules les femmes sont coquettes et que
les hommes ne se déguise jamais alors ça
m'a donné l'idée d'un jeu je vais vous
montrer toutes sortes de chapeaux et
vous allez me dire qu'ils les portent ou
qui les portaient parce que certains
sont d'époque
d'accord on va les chercher aussi
allégée du premier chapeau magnifique
celui ci est un fait ça alors comment
s'appelle ce chapeau crise porn day et
bien c'est un chapeau de grenadiers de
la gamme de napoléon
en réalité il manque une pièce qui
manque un plus mais sur le côté et ça
pourrait aussi être un chapeau dehors
squarred connaissez leurs joueurs c'est
la garde de la reine en angleterre à
l'égard de la leyre ouais tiens casimir
terreux bref on dirait une belle plein
de poils à notre chapeau julie sait d'où
un gpo voilà un gars bruit c'est un
casque de garde quel hôtel garde si le
casque de la garde républicaine à cheval
de paris
ayez la ja les cuissots de la ville de
paris tu veux mais patrick sergeant
c'est l'ouvragé pour les lourdes
en voilà en quarts à paris les bogies
d'auxi
c'est pas un chapeau c'est un chapeau
mais sacha qui s'appelle un képi comme
du deal très bien christelle de generali
l'on pousse de vie mais là ce avait
deviné oui je sais tout ce que vous non
plus le postal illimythics encore
portera bien que très bien celui là
effectivement tout le monde connaît
ouais et c'est également écrit moi comme
le képi du général tient jean-françois
celui-là ça provient non non non c'est
porte pas dans ce sens là c'est pas
napoléon
non ils se portent comme ça napoléon
c'était dans ce sens là qu'ils n'avaient
pas des petits poils comme ça au dessus
quel est ce jeu plumes et des broderies
comme ça tu vois c'est dans ce sens que
ce jeudi oui alors et un chapeau
d'académiciens voilà il veut de la
collision
[Musique]
celui là haut c'est mon cargaison
beaucoup moins coloré celui ci puis
c'est vrai vous rappelle rien qu'est ce
que c'est et procès police et une toque
une toque de juge tiens on va voir si ça
doit christelle ça va mal et séduit la
vérité sinon oui ça c'est un chapeau
demain avec le poteau je me poserai
célèbre christine sylvie là à nous nous
penchons ça ressemble aux cowboys mais
ça n'est pas c'est un chapeau espagnol a
sombré ronde et ça ça sert
elle fixe et où elle rejetée en arrière
pour qu'ils tiennent qu'à stéphanie va
bien et celui là ça c'est très habillée
qu'est ce que c'est c'est à haute forme
c'est un chapeau il va avec un habit de
cérémonie évidente à trouver une salle
de presse appelle une mitre c'est une
mitre d'évêque c'est magnifique
regardez les mecs extraordinaires
voilà encore un facile qui désigné
cuisinier et ça s'appelle une toque une
toque de cuisinier
quand tu veux regarder qui a déjà deux
d'entre eux
et le dernier mot
il ressemble aussi à celui de napoléon
c'est le bicorne de napoléon une
reproduction évidemment et il est porté
aussi par les gendarmes
thurella autres julie non c'est terminé
c'est alors que mon exposition de
chapeau elle était val c'était vraiment
et françoise que tu pense toujours que
seules les femmes portent des chapeaux
évidemment juge j avais pas songé aux
uniformes mais reconnaît que les hommes
portent de moins en moins ce genre de
coiffure oui bien sûr mais les femmes
n'ont plus de lait porte par regarde les
chapeaux que j'avais tout à l'heure ne
sont pas portés par les femmes à l'heure
actuelle il serait mode et c'est vrai je
lis tu as raison mais alors qui est le
plus coquets d2 c'est moi au casimir
moi j'ai vraiment une tête à chapeaux
[Musique]